[Music]
hey piece of [ __ ]
[Applause]
in our new hotshot driver with a
promising career dominate off-road
racing on his way to the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there's a scheme calling there's a
wreck that charger crawling up our
champions worth it brilliant you know
that's the skill that wins no matter
what the engine filled anyone the track
[Music]
champion coming out of nowhere to rise
to the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you two years back the
crew to the driving genre out there to
the big wide open world of the USA
thanks to our players we have taken with
iconic vision to the next level they
showed us what they like and what they
wanted to see in the futures now it's
time to take it way beyond driving i am
stefan beret creative director this is
the crew - yeah thank thank
yeah in the u.s. motor sports are louder
bigger AG than anywhere else in the
world drivers and fans meet across the
country and celebrate a common passion
for all things motorized now's your
chance to join in ladies and gentlemen
welcome to virtru - all of modern nation
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in the heart of the city street racers
prove their skills skidding on rooftops
burning asphalt and tuning their rides
[Music]
[Music]
forge your own path off road through the
striking beauty of nature
tail and predictable ways on the open
ocean rapid waters or narrow rivers
fearless pirate rules guys spin between
buildings through the clouds
among stunning stunning perspectives
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all across the country I obtained
contest a will you take the lead on
modern Asian you've had a glimpse of the
crew to register now for beta access or
player Jimo at the booth experience TC 2
for yourself
enjoy the ride thank you
[Applause]